um
[Music]
hey guys chris bryan here um i want to
take a moment just to talk to you
about um myself and my approach to ikea
and
trying to explain a little um about who
i am as a person and
how i feel more uh work um and i think a
lot of times when i talk about aikido
people
get the wrong impression and think that
um i'm like a passive
or kind of a picky kind of guy and i'm
like you know everything in the world
about trying to resolve something right
trying to make something fit together in
a way that
maybe naturally wouldn't fit together
nicely i have competed in lots of
martial arts
um and that's because when i was young i
kind of looked at the world as something
you had to resist and overcome and my
mindset was
i'm going to dominate and overcome the
world and so i need to be strong
and understanding how the world works
now that doesn't mean
that i am a pacifist so understanding
that the world
necessary in order to stop that from
happening i am a firearms owner i'm an
nra certified
would like to solve it before you listen
to that and so
i feel something that gives you a skill
set to keep it from getting
closer down the line so i really feel
really good
you would never have to use those skills
i'd really like to use a great martial
art for two kinds of people
um one kind of person is the person who
wants to basically live a peaceful life
is not looking to dominate or control
anyone and wants to be a positive
influence around them everybody feels
really good for living a peaceful life
um i also believe uh there's another
person that the other intersection that
is really good for
um and that kind of person is someone
who's constantly in conflict
and they realize it's free that is they
can't
beat up everyone no matter how skilled
they become they can't beat
i can run real far i can do all kinds of
athletic stuff
i'm skilled in martial arts with weapons
and without weapons
my own firearms and have the means to
defend myself to a very serious degree
if i need to
having said all that there are
definitely tons of people and forces
that can overcome me in the world
lots of them but there are tons of
people who could beat me into doing
this or mma or stick fighting or sword
fighting or gun play or whatever right
so there's all kinds of people who can
defeat me
um and all these things and i recognize
that and so i recognized that if i were
ever to get in a situation with one of
those people
physically dominating them is not the
cards for me they're just greater than i
am
so i need to know a skill set that
enables me to deal with
that kind of situation right so i
believe this is at the heart of what it
was said when
uh you know you wish people would only
uh train people who already had studied
other martial arts and it's because um
they probably had that idea and felt the
ability to dominate when including and
yet also understood that they can't
always be the most dominant force and so
either people who are ready to live a
peaceful life or people who know
in the extreme end of it um you can't
dominate everyone so how do you make a
chord
when when you can't dominate everywhere
i just wanted to explain a little bit
about myself and that uh i'm in no way a
pacifist
and i've spent a lot of time doing a lot
of hard training because i know that the
world's harsh
there are definitely times when you need
to be strong capable
and resist and use weapons and all kinds
of stuff however i want to give myself
the greatest buffer
ever having to do that again and so
that's why the main martial art i study
in practice these days
is aikido because i believe it does
exactly that it gives you a giant buffer
so there's a time in life where you need
to go and fight and become strong
um is not the best martial arts study
when it's that time for you and it's
that time for you you used to be
studying mma
you should be going out and doing uh
intense stuff join the military if you
have an opportunity to do that
um you need to undertake difficult
strenuous hard
things um and and that's probably not
ideal so if you're the kind of person
right now who's like
oh man you know i want to just crush
everyone and dominate and learn these
super sweet techniques to throw people
hard
i think it's probably not the martial
art for you there's a lot of other
avenues you can take that will be much
more efficient in teaching you how to do
those things
and give you the resistance you need you
need to be around athletic strong people
all the time
who are going to push and challenge you
um and if you're not constantly doing
that then you're not going to get better
at fighting
whereas i feel something to train with
anybody because it's about making a
chores and those things can be
mental or spiritual if you will or
physical as well so
um i believe viktor's martial arts is
really good for for some kinds of people
and not good for other kinds of people
and i think that's all fair right
i've definitely been on both ends of
those spectrums myself
and i don't think anyone should feel
guilty about playing another martial
arts so you know almost like i don't
like you though so i shouldn't stop in
the night video you're not banning
aikido by learning more
in fact you learn more and then you may
be appreciate aikido for what it is more
anyway i'm not rambling anymore i'm
christopher hines thanks for watching
[Music]